dans les territoires occupés sa vocation
a fait des lune cible Victoria et
professeur d'histoire il y a des jours
elle a quitté la région de berdionk
occupé par les forces russes au premier
jour de l'invasion chaque matin elle
enregistre les cours pour ses élèves
rester en zone occupée maintenant on va
regarder attentivement la carte la carte
de l'Ukraine on voit ici les frontières
de l'Ukraine moderne ce programme est
dangereux les occupants viennent dans
les maisons vivent des enfants
scolarisés ils cherchent leurs cours sur
les appareils et les efface ou alors il
les confisquent et les casse
à la fin du mois de juin Victoria et ses
collègues enseignants sont convoqués par
les soldats russes il leur ordonne
d'enseigner le Programme russe dans la
langue russe et d'aller se former en
Crimée
on a été convoqué deux fois
la première fois ils nous ont rassemblés
les soldats nous ont dit qu'on devait
coopérer d'une manière assez ferme on a
refusé ils ont dit d'accord on va
ramener nos profs
au début on ne sait pas senti menacé
deux semaines plus tard on a été de
nouveau convoqué par d'autres soldats le
commandant a été très dur et on nous a
enfermés dans une pièce
psychologiquement c'était dur
Victoria prend le risque d'enregistrer
en cachette les intimidations de
l'officier elle nous fait écouter ses
enregistrements il s'adresse à elle
[Musique]
deux mois plus tard Victoria et sa
famille non plus le choix il partent une
école de la ville où elle est désormais
réfugiée lui a proposé un poste Victoria
a choisi de continuer à enseigner à
distance à ses élèves qui étudient dans
la clandestine